hello and welcome to math simplify it
the immune system is your body's number
one defense mechanism which protects you
from various types of bacteria viruses
and other disease-causing pathogens your
immune system and your health are
directly related the stronger immune
system the more protection you will have
against colds viruses and other
illnesses that can attack your body on
the other hand a weak immunity can make
you more vulnerable to frequent colds
sinus infections and sloven healing as
well as causing a Nemea of fatigue and
lethargy various factors can make your
immunity weaker and render you
susceptible to diseases and you may be
surprised to learn that many common
daily habits actually harm your immune
system in fact most of your habits
directly impact your immune system
especially as you age to keep your
immune system strong is important to
adopt healthy habits and quit the bad
ones let's look at the top ten everyday
habits that directly harm your immunity
if you work late nights or like watching
TV or doing projects late into the night
you may have a wee community poor sleep
habits lower the immune systems
functioning and reduce your level of
killer white blood cells that fight
germs sleep deprivation
also reduces the production of
protective cytokines while you sleep
your immune system releases different
types of cytokines and help to protect
your body against infections and
diseases whose production can
significantly decrease if you are sleep
deprived in a 2017 study published in
Journal of sleep researchers took blood
samples from 11 pairs of identical twins
but different sleep patterns and found
that the twin with the shorter sleep
duration had a depressed immune system
and with reduced activity of lymphocytes
in the blood compared with his or her
sibling avoid skipping on sleep develop
a proper sleep hygiene be in the bed at
a fixed time every night and try to wake
up at the same time every morning be
sure to get seven to nine hours of
quality sleep every night
if you often eat or drink something's
read to satisfy your cravings you can
suffer from weak immunity
refined sugar can reduce the ability of
white blood cells to kill germs sugar
actually prevents vitamin C from getting
into the white blood cells resulting in
a weakened immunity interestingly the
immune suppressing effects of sugar
starts within 30 minutes after ingestion
and may last for many hours if you need
to eat something sweet to go for fruits
like oranges apples mangoes watermelons
and others that contain natural sugars
to satisfy your cravings the vitamin C
in these fruits will also help your
immune system to work in a more
efficient manner
the benefits that a daily glass of wine
can contribute to cardiovascular health
is scientifically proven but excessive
consumption of alcoholic beverages can
throw away all the benefits of moderate
consumption in addition not all
alcoholic beverages have the same
benefits of wine many have a high
alcohol level that cannot be metabolized
by the body depressing the ability of
the immune system also excessive alcohol
consumption reduces the production of
white blood cells slows down digestive
activity and overloads liver work
reducing his ability to store vitamins
all these factors contribute to the poor
immunity in alcoholics
if the control consumption of some
alcoholic beverages can be accepted in
the case of tobacco there is no limit
allowed cigarettes contain more than 250
highly harmful substances some of which
are even considered poisonous such as
ammonia arsenic nicotine and toluene the
human body is not made to process
chemicals as potent and devastating as
those contained in the cigarettes slowly
smoking affects all systems of the human
body and the immune system is no
exception
drinking too much coffee and other
caffeinated beverages is also not good
for your immunity excessive caffeine
stimulates your nervous system by
increasing the stress level in the body
a high stress level causes the release
of stress hormones like cortisol
cortisol is also known to suppress the
immune system and make you more prone to
infections and other health problems
elevated cortisol is also linked to
health issues related to the heart blood
sugar and high cholesterol when taken in
moderation coffee provides many health
benefits like increased alertness mood
and energy so limit yourself to just 1
to 2 cups of coffee per day
eating junk food in excess can be bad
for your immunity junk food is often
high in fat and eating excess fat is one
of the key reasons behind obesity a diet
high in saturated fat
can harm the immune system even before
the way it came begins to show obesity
can affect the ability of the white
blood cells to multiply and produce
antibodies thus making you more prone to
infections
a 2014 study bubbly
in nutritional journal reports that the
Western diet is characterized by an
overconsumption of refined sugars salt
and saturated fat which has a negative
impact on immunity it can lead to
increase inflammation reduce control of
infection increased rates of cancer and
increased risk of allergic and
autoimmune diseases cut down on fast
food and choose a healthy diet instead
the human body is mostly made of water
in every cell of our body as 2o performs
numerous functions if you don't drink
enough water to replenish what your body
needs it will surely affect your immune
system proper hydration is essential for
building a stronger immunity
in 2013 animal study published in
frontiers of zoology researchers
concluded that depending upon the life
history of an organism osmotic state may
have a greater influence on immune
function than energy availability which
in simple words means water is more
important for immune function than food
a healthy person should drink about
eight to ten glasses of water per day
however the amount of water you drink
may depend upon the climate in which you
live how physically active you are and
your overall health
lack of regular physical activity is
harmful in every way for the body the
sedentary lifestyle literally makes the
immune system sleep engaging in any
sport or some form of physical exercise
activates it to fight viral and
bacterial infections and decreases a
likelihood of suffering from chronic
diseases such as osteoporosis arthritis
or heart disease
exercise reduces stress and increases
the production of antibodies and white
blood cells on the other hand when we
work out our body temperature rises and
elevation of body temperature reduces
the possibility of bacterial growth on
your body physical activity is essential
for building a stronger immunity and
there is no doubt about it but that
brings us to our next point which lowers
our immunity which is excessive exercise
your body has a limit and when you try
to push it beyond its physical limits it
stops functioning correctly
your immune system also stops responding
efficiently and you fall prey to
infections easily researchers showed
that more than 90 minutes of
high-intensity exercise can make you
more susceptible to illness for up to 72
hours after the exercise session intense
exercise seems to cause a temporary
decrease in immune function researchers
have found that during these intense
physical exertion periods the body
produces certain hormones that
temporarily lower the immunity cortisol
and adrenaline are stress hormones
perform numerous important functions in
our body but they also raise blood
pressure and cholesterol levels and they
also suppress the immune system this
effect has been linked to increased
susceptibility to infections in
endurance athletes after extreme
exercises always ensure that you take
proper rest and do not overwork yourself
heavy long-term exercise such as
marathon running and intense
gym training have been proven to lower
your immunity and decrease its ability
to fight viral infections
believe it or not avoiding people or
human connections can also affect you
immunity social relationships both the
quantity and quality affect our mental
health which affects our health behavior
and indirectly affects our immunity as
well
people who have poor
relations usually run at least twice the
risk of serious illnesses and premature
death compared to the people who have
good social relations if you want to be
healthier you cannot avoid other people
like it or not the human body is built
to be a part of society and putting time
and effort into positively interacting
with others will inevitably bring you
many health benefits if nothing else
a good diet is essential to build a
healthy immune system and fight off
infections click on the screen to check
out our new video about the top 10 foods
that help to boost your immunity you can
also check out the other videos on
immune system and the topic of immunity
on our channel to have more knowledge
about this topic thank you for watching
this video I hope you like this see you
in the next one bye and take care of you
and your family